réactions tout ce soir de françois
meunier de l'association des
restaurateurs du québec bonsoir mon sens
du client alors la nouvelle subvention
pour le loyer est quand même pas mal
plus un plan que la précédente mais elle
arrive quand même six à huit mois plus
tard la formule st comment c'est reçu
mais il faut quand même dire une
excellente nouvelle on en a besoin
absolument de cet être là et on salue la
que le gunner fédéral les ferments
d'honorables changer le modèle beaucoup
plus simple géré par l' agence du revenu
du canada
on nous a dit aujourd'hui que les
entreprises qui ont déjà aidé aussi à
l'agent ce que pourraient penser avoir
un versement dans leur halle à leur
compte aussi ok le cap des 100
exactement exactement donc le 4 décembre
ça vient rapidement ce qui vient pas
rapidement à ce moment c'est l'aide du
gouvernement du québec qui est annoncé
au début du mois d'octobre pour payer
les coûts fixes et ça semble tomber
lentement ou pas du tout qu'est ce que
vous en savez écouter l'album s'appelle
l'aide aux entreprises pour les
régionales maximale
ça a été annoncé le 1er octobre et c'est
vrai que oui le programme le paiement
met du temps à arriver
beaucoup d'entreprises des jeunes qui
ont fait des demandes et qui n'ont pas
encore vu la couleur de l'aide mais vous
savez pour nous garder les restera là en
2020 devons être d'abord avoir été
fermée six mois six mois là c'est
catastrophique non pas de perte de vente
qui vont dépasser les 5 milliards de
dollars alors c'est extrêmement
important
donc le problème est plus profond que de
voir l'argent arrive est lente mais
monsieur fillion s'est davantage mène la
philosophie du programme convainc
question on est en crise présentement
une crise qui est hors du commun
convenons-en et on devrait avoir des
programmes died qui sont adaptés à cette
crise là qu'est ce qui change de
programme actuellement plongé le
programme présente pas comme un
programme d'investissement un programme
de prêt est certain c'est pas ma que
nous on a besoin de subventions qu'on a
besoin d'être de direct après on en
douze entreprises actuellement de
démontrer qu'elles sont rentables
on demande aux entreprises de démontrer
qu'elles ont une capacité très toutes
les entreprises ce cas de la
restauration leur ont été fermées trouve
au printemps à ce moment alors elles se
sont endettés jusqu'au cou
alors notre inquiétude c'est de voir
énormément de refus parce que finalement
peut-être que les dossiers de crédit
elles seront pas assez positif au goût
du gouvernement pour pouvoir leur
accorder l'aide tant attendue parce que
le gouvernement veut aider des
entreprises qui vont survivre après la
crise
alors il vous demande de prouver que
vous êtes capable de de traverser cette
crise là pour vous aider c'est ça ouais
mais gardez là c'est carrément des
élèves déraisonnable ont convié tout
cela je voulais dit tantôt six mois de
fermeture des restaurants qui est en
mesure présentement de sortir la tête de
l'eau à peu près personne ne sait pas
les prêtes à manger et les livraisons
que les qui vont nous permettre de
survivre et on bloque pas les villes ni
lmrc qui ont conquis on a la
responsabilité d'annie ce programme là
elles de leur côté elles doivent faire
preuve de vigilance elle doit démontrer
que qu'elles ont fait le nécessaire
parce que l'argent qu'il aurait préparé
bien qu'elles devront rembourser
l'argent
dans dix ans donc si elles perdent leurs
investissements parce que les
entreprises ont fait faillite mais les
villes sont frileuses
alors ce qui est inquiétant c'est de
voir les entreprises le dossier à
présent refusé de voir qu'on demande des
cautionnements personnel ou encore une
bureaucratie qui est beaucoup trop
lourde pour un petit restaurant qui qui
a besoin d'être dans les circonstances
les dernières données disponibles au
pays ne montre pas qu'il ya une hausse
de faillite sur le dit pourquoi comment
ça s'explique que les faillites ne soit
pas en train d'exploser alors qu'il ya
tant de situations pénibles et
désastreuse pourtant d'entreprise
nous on pense qu'on vit sur du temps
emprunté monsieur piliers on pense que
les programmes dyke particulièrement au
fédéral le conte d'urgence pour les
entreprises
la subvention salariale d'urgence tout
ce qui est arrivé à gauche à droite le
pour nous permettent de passer à travers
la crise ont certainement eu leur effet
la saison estivale a été quand même
profitable pour plusieurs ports tout le
monde montréal a été durement touchée
convenons-en québec aussi mais c'est
probablement davantage les prochains
mois qu'ils nous donneront un meilleur
portrait de la situation ce qui concerne
les failles et les fêtes
après les fêtes surtout s'ils demandent
l'aide de l'état n'arrive pas françois
meunier merci beaucoup pour cette
entrevue ce soir merci de m'avoir reçu